life hello welcome to chess openings
explained i'm nick riscoe your
instructor for tonight and this is part
three of our scotch series we are going
through
part one was all the third move
sidelines black could play uh and that
featured the napoleon gambit
uh part two
is all about the bishop c5 scotch gambit
lines
and here part three we're going to be
covering the knight f6 scotch gambit
lines
including
the nakmansen gambit
the one and only
so we're going to get right into it
we're going to cover the scotch gambit
position here
we have our scotch starting
position and after takes the scotch
gambit is with bishop to c4 you don't
recapture on d4 right away instead
you're just giving that pawn up for free
in order to get activity with your
pieces
so here after bishop c4 black does have
two main options they have bishop to c5
and they have knight to f6 now again in
part two we looked at all the bishops to
c5 options
tonight we're looking at knight to f6
we have tracy coming in hi tracy hello
we fixing the camera
awesome
okay so after knight to f6
white has a couple different options but
we're going to be focusing on two main
options tonight our two main options are
going to be
pawn to e5 and we're also going to be
looking at castles king side
so these are two
moves we're going to investigate
so here after knight to f6 in the lead
chest database is known as the dubois
ready defense
and white
most popularly continues with the move
e5
and it makes some sense you're hitting
the knight that just moved and if it
moves back to g8 it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense here as the knight has
already moved
so we're going to take a look at the
main line with d5 and then we're going
to look at the two side lines black has
with knight to g4 and knight to e4
both of which i believe are playable
so okay after e5
our main line is pawn to d5 and the
point is you're ignoring the fact white
is hitting your knight because you are
making a threat to capture on c4 and
this may be a favorable trade to black
because if they can take on c4
1 they get the bishop pair which can be
a nice uh benefit in this open position
and two
once they capture these are two
connected pawns in the center
so a lot of center control
so white doesn't really want to allow
them to take on c4 so taking on f6 would
be a mistake
instead white does best simply by
playing bishop to b5 and what they're
doing here is creating a pin
and this knight is no longer putting
pressure on e5 and it's also no longer
guarding d4 because this is an absolute
pin
so here black normally continues with
knight to e4 your knight was still
attacked so you have to move it and what
better place than a centralized square
supported by a pawn
uh we have nikki christopher in the
chats hello gone up about 300 ratings
since switching to the scotch that's
awesome to hear it's awesome 300 rating
points with the scotch i wish i gained
300 rating points when i switched to the
scotch
okay so knight e4 how are we going to
fight in the center uh well let's take
on d4 with the knight it would make
sense to take with the knight um i
believe it's possible to take with the
queen because this knight cannot move
however i like the fact that whenever we
recapture with the knight we are putting
more pressure onto c6
so uh black now has to respond to this
and they have two options here
two rather good options i believe um i
should also mention the lines we're
looking at tonight are not always going
to favor white
i believe the knight f6 lines are a
pretty good try against the scotch
gambit might be giving it a run for its
money
so not everything is going to be all all
perfect for white there are gonna be
lines where white is worse
and before we look at bishop to d7 we're
going to take a look at bishop to c5
so bishop to c5 is an interesting move
here
you are developing and the very first
question you might have is
why don't we just take on c6 here
well if you take on c6 with the knight
black has this inner meso with bishop
takes f2 check and the king has to go to
f1
and now they can capture on c6 captures
and then king f8 and after king f8 if
you take this rook
it's really bad for white as bishop a6
is going to
come at the king and the only way to
stop this is to give up your queen
so
not a big fan of this for white
what happens if you take on c6 with the
bishop
they can take with the pawn and this
should be fine
but
don't go expecting to take again because
of similar ideas of bishop f2 followed
by bishop a6 so unfortunately this just
doesn't work as soon as this b pawn
leaves this is a nice open diagonal for
the bishop
so after bishop to c5
white should just simply
bring the piece out bishop to e3 and
defend the knight
and now bishop to d7 breaking this pin
and now there is some tension going on
in the center
uh white doesn't need to worry about
this they can capture on c6 with the
bishop
and then they will retake with the pawn
and it's a little important they retake
with the pawn here if you trade off the
bishop and then there's a trade i don't
see what benefit there is for black for
giving up the bishop pair and
compromising his well not really
compromising but ruining his structure
here
so
i i think it's just best if you take
with pawn keep the bishop on the board
does give you some nice control over
here on the king side stops moves such
as queen to g4
so just take with the pawn and it's
almost like um black stealing with the
reverse winner
uh at least that's the pattern it
reminds me of
but okay white can castle here and after
castling queen e7 delaying castling
rook to e1 lining itself up with the
queen
and black actually needs to be careful
here this pawn on e5 is not a free pawn
so what happens if black takes i want to
give chat just a second see if they can
find the tactic
can you believe it the center is this
closed and there's a tactic
so rookie one lined the rook up with the
king and the queen
how can we take advantage of this
anybody in chat
f3 chasing away the knight and
threatening to pin the queen by star
princess 99 that is correct f3 is the
best move in the position
and the point is that if the knight
moves somewhere like d6 well now you can
just back your bishop up to f2
and there is this pin of the queen to
the king
and uh blocking with the knight really
doesn't help because you win the piece
so if black cannot move this knight
they should just move the bishop back or
something and just give up the knight in
the first place
in this specific position you don't even
have to take right away you can let this
sit as
if the knight does move on black's next
turn you still have bishop to f2
so
very nice finding the tactic so this
pawn is poison black cannot take it
so that's why we will see black castle
after castling f3 is the main move
kicking the knight out of its nice
outpost and the only square for this
knight to go is to g5
once we see knight to g5 we do see that
black still has pressure here with their
dark square bishop their light squared
bishop is on an open diagonal but not
really attacking much and the knight to
me at least looks a little out of place
because it's really hard to see where
it's going other than e6
so we are likely to see black reroute
the knight and white is just going to
develop the rest of their pieces with
knight c3 after knight e6 we can see
white continue with something like queen
d2
and now we're starting to get out of the
opening a little bit
this is where black can start looking to
trade off some pieces trying to get into
some sort of end game
um but i did want to show at least after
queen to b4
uh this does come with a threat
hitting the bishop and the pawn
the way you can remedy this is actually
just giving up the pawn on b2
and white will get um almost full
compensation here
um after a3 threatening to trap the
queen with rook to b1
so queen b7 and now after
f4
white does have a lot of space for the
pawn a rook will make its way to the b
file maybe find its way on the seventh
rank and hit some targets so white does
have this idea of giving up the pawn and
that is why it continued with this line
so that should cover
the
um
the bishop to c5 line here on move seven
the other move black has that is more
popular
is bishop to d7
and this is interrupting the pin
immediately
and white kind of needs to make a
decision about what he's going to do on
c6 is he going to trade is he not well
we notice that if we take with the
bishop
black does better to take with the pawn
so we at least get this out of our
opponent that we double up their pawns
and we're going to hope that's going to
be a long-term weakness
and we'll see white castle
after castling black does have another
decision to make and it's about this
dark squared bishop
and what square they are going to
develop too
uh they can go bishop to e7 this is fine
this is probably the sideline of the
position
and we're going to see white very
commonly play f3 f4 f5 all in a row
um and you do it with tempo on the
knights so black has to has to do
something about this knight that way
you're not just pushing the pawn and
they get to make some other improving
move so f3 and the knight moves
sometimes if it goes to g5 you can just
play f4 right away
um so after knight c5 we just continue
f4 gaining space
and after black castles we do play f5
and there's this very interesting idea
white has of sacrificing both of the
pawns in order to try and get at the
king
so going with this idea
black goes knight e4 this is also very
common after you move the knight away as
soon as it's available to put the knight
back on e4 black can do very well just
by putting it there right away
and in this specific scenario
after knight c3 and bishop to c5
we see a trade of knights
and then after king h1 breaking the pin
of the the knight to the king and rookie
8 we will see white sacrifice the pawns
starting with e6
so e6 is going to be our big break here
after f takes instead of taking back on
e6 where white is just going to be
losing the pawn
we're actually going to push
and force black to take with their pawn
they also have rook f8 here
we can go f7 check and the king moves
and bishop to e3 and white is doing
pretty well this pawn is kind of keeping
this rook trapped for now
and our knight and bishop are developed
i think this is fine
black's pawn structure is also
not really a structure
these can be weaknesses
so after f6 um g takes is the most
popular move
and is met with queen to g4 trek
so queen g4 track king h8 is the only
move in this position if black tries
anything else like king to f7 this is
met with queen to h5 and if something
like king 2 g8 well the bishop hangs
so
uh king two h8 is the only move for
black
and now the best move for white is to
win at least one of the pawns back with
queen takes e4
um most often you'll see black trade off
the bishop for the knight and f6 is a
big weakness here if black doesn't
protect f6 uh white can just take with
the rook and we'll have a happy day
uh
but we're going to assume our opponent
knows what they're doing they're going
to play e5 they're going to stop you
from taking on f6
and now white must keep up the pressure
so they can do this by playing queen h4
and black is just going to have to
defend f6 for the time being with rook
e6
bishop e3 finally developing the rest of
our pieces
queen to e7 and rook a to d1 will
activate white's final piece
and this here
is a very balanced position for both
sides i think white is doing a very good
job at keeping up the pressure this king
on h8
is not as safe as this king on h1
white has both rooks on open files
and again massive pressure on f6 so i
think white is doing just fine here some
ideas they might
you know try and play around with is
rook f3 to rook h3 this is very direct
in putting pressure against the king
maybe even just going to g3 getting on
the file
um
yeah i think there's a lot of play here
for white
i think a little bit safer for black
instead of going bishop e7
is uh going bishop c5 and putting a bit
of pressure on this knight right away
asking white what are they going to do
and we're going to see the same theme f3
hitting the knight and the knight moves
and f4
and the knight moves back to e4 and we
see bishop to e3
after bishop to e3 this bishop is a
little loose so
um maybe something like knight f5
looking to trade off the dark square
bishops may be in white's future
um
like if black just plays a6 here
um even knight d2 just looking to trade
off our
uh kind of undeveloped knight for
black's really awesome knight on e4
should be very good for white so
black backs up this bishop kind of loses
the tempo um
they are securing their bishop though so
i will give them that
um but white can continue with knight d2
again looking to trade off their knight
for black's very active knight on e4
and black really doesn't have anything
better to do than trade if they don't
trade it then white can take and then
the pawn on e4 will become a weakness
in in turn black will get this counter
play with c5 they do have the bishop
pair
after the knight moves
d4 hitting the bishop bishop f2
and bishop to c6 and
um i do have
a lot more moves here but i don't think
it's very important to go through the
rest of these is like the main line
theory i pulled from lee chess
um but here is pretty much the position
that a lot of people
i guess
try to stay away from if you're white if
you're playing the scotch gambit i don't
see why you want to go for this this is
a bit more of a positional
approach
to the game rather than you know cut
throat tactics checkmating the king this
is going to be a bit more strategic so
if you like that from white cool you can
go for this um i want i do want to cover
the two sidelines for the dubai ready um
and then we're gonna get into what
people play if they don't like this
approach
um
so the first variation we have
after
knight to f6 e5 is knight to g4
and this is putting pressure on e5 right
away white kind needs to address this
immediately they don't need to they can
castle if black ends up taking on e5
knight takes e5 knight takes e5 and rook
e1 is going to be very good for white
queen e7 is like the best move to
protect the knights but f4 will win the
piece so
immediately
it's tactically defended after castles
so black should go bishop to e7
and the point behind bishop e7 over c5
is that you're shutting this file so
rook e1 is not going to be as big of a
concern
white will continue with rookie one
anyway to help support this pawn
and now black does best by starting to
chip away
at this pawn that white has in the
center
there's really no reason not to capture
and now black has to make a decision
um
it's uh
do you take on d6 with the queen or do
you take on d6 with the pawn
um as black there's definitely arguments
to both
um but i think the the better try might
be
a little less
intuitive
just catching up on chat here
all right people are allergic to
positional games good because because
after these two lines we're not gonna
look at any more positional stuff we're
gonna look at uh
we're gonna look at sharp chess
okay so after pawn takes on d6
black would love to take with the bishop
unfortunately that's not possible
we're going to take a look at queen
takes on d6 first
and here
it was a little surprising to me to see
how white should continue here
immediately i was thinking of something
like okay maybe g3 and bishop f4 but
this seems a little slow at the same
time
there are some other nice ideas
right now there's no threat of checkmate
because you do have the knight on f3
one very direct approach is to play b3
and possibly
get bishop to b2 and win the d pawn but
maybe even better than that we can play
bishop to a3 and maybe do something
about this pinned bishop
so after b3 we see black castle break
the pin
which
is what they should do
uh bishop to a3
skewering the queen so we can trade off
the bishops
and after the knight recaptures this
pawn will hang we can take with the
queen queen takes knight takes
and here we notice the material is equal
white has their bishop developed on c4
which
i don't think is
a particularly bad thing i also don't
know if i can quite say this is the
absolute best square for the bishop
naturally i would put it on d3 but as it
is right now on c4 it's perfectly fine
this knight on d4 very well placed
centralized it's ready to go back to f3
if it's attacked you may even have
knight b5 to c7
and after you move this knight off of b1
uh you will have very nice development
now this does still continue black does
have some nice tries starting with
knight to f5 your knight was attacked so
you have to do something to defend it
and if you trade which white normally
does
the bishop develops with an attack on
the pawn on c2
and here i think the best try for white
is just to go rook e7 i don't care about
the c2 pawn you can take it because uh
i'm putting pressure on your c7
uh if you just take on c2
i can take on c7
and here we're doing just fine there's
even ideas of bishop takes f7 and rook
takes on c2 if black is not careful for
instance knight f6
well first b7 hangs but again i don't
think this idea is too bad either
just taking the pawn and here
white is for choice you have a clean
pawn on the king side
so after rookie seven uh you do see
black defend
the c7 pawn still threatening c2
but now again instead of reacting to
black's threat white just says okay
that's fine i'm going to go bishop to uh
d5 and you can either hit the b7 pawn
or even knight c3 first with the point
being that if the bishop takes on c2
now you can go something like rook c1
and you will have some time to your side
much more active pieces i i think in my
opinion
so
i think this is going to be just fine
for white
um after
pawn takes you can also take with your
own pawn on d6
so uh
v94 in the chat says they prefer c takes
d6 it seems safer and i agree i think
this might be a better try for black
with white
one of the lines i i found attractive
was just bishop to g5 just hitting this
bishop on e7 again
and asking black what are you going to
do about this
um if they try f6 this is pretty
weakening they'll no longer be able to
castle on the king side unless they take
drastic measures
so i think um this is fine you just drop
the bishop all the way back to c1 even
and white will be better
so i i don't have any problem with
bishop to g5 as far as you know that's
concerned the real concern is going to
be what happens if black blocks the file
and then starts trying to trade off
pieces
in this scenario uh first you have to
take on e7 if you don't take on e7 you
do run the risk of losing this bishop so
takes takes and then bishop to e2 you
can save your bishop and just retreat it
and if they take on f3 you can take with
the bishop instead of the pawn
so bishop to e2
and i think safest for black is just
castle you don't want to worry about
having the queen and the king on the
same file as the rook anymore
and here white can take on d4
and after bishop to e6 i think black has
caught up fine they do have this
isolated queen's pawn which i can't find
a way for white to really exploit at
this current moment
and the game might just continue with
knight to c3
and uh black bringing their pieces to
the center and this is starting to leave
the scope of an opening this is starting
to get into middle game and end game
plans
um so we're going to cut this off here
for knight g4
um
someone else in the chat saying if they
take the knight they lose the queen
what are we talking about here
probably some other line i i missed
whenever they put it in the chat
um
let's see
okay
um
yeah so that covers knight g4 let's move
into
fifth move knight to e4 and then we'll
get into what everyone's here for the
nakmansen so the last line of the dubois
ready defense
the scotch scotch gambit
do already
e5 knight to e4
and this is a sideline looking to put
pressure on f2
um white can do best by castling
securing the f2 square not really
needing to worry about any sacrifices
and black tries with d5 hitting the
bishop supporting the knight opening up
a line for their bishop
and white should take they take what
they're upon
and black takes with their knight so
we're looking at this position white is
down upon and now we see you know where
scotch gambit comes from white is just
down the pawn and needs to rely on their
peace activity
bishop to d5 if you end up going bishop
to b3
um
first
black can end up playing bishop to g4
and be fine after this trade is made
i don't see any problems that have been
added to black's position
but i'm also wondering if knight a5 can
just be played
i cannot because of queen e1
that would explain why it's not in my
notes
um
yeah you can't just uh try going for
this bishop it does fail
so
okay bishop d5 a nice active square for
the bishop
here i can't really get hit by anything
if a bishop to e6 looking for a trade
you can take on c6 and double the pawns
and actually just remove the defender of
the d-pawn and this should be a really
nice position for white i believe i
might have even had that one in a game
before
um
cyto bishop d5 black really should just
focus on completing their development as
fast as possible
um and white is going to take on c6 and
remove the defender of this pawn so okay
white has gotten their pawn back
and is starting to
develop their pieces in an active
position try and make use of the fact
that these pawns are doubled and
isolated and this might come way later
in the game we see black castle
and bishop to f4 developing to nice
natural square but you're not looking to
capture on d6 if you capture on d6 black
can simply recapture with their pawn fix
their pawn structure or maybe even just
take with the bishop and maybe in the
future they'll have something like
bishop g4 takes on f3 and queen h4
so not really looking to capture right
away just looking to develop get that
piece off of the back rank
and there is this idea of rook 2 b8 and
at first it looks like this pawn on a7
is hanging but do not take it if you
take it they can take on b2 and now
black's pieces are starting to look
active and white's positional plus with
their pawn structure is starting to
disappear
instead
b3
b3 supporting it with the other pawns
there's no problem with this i don't see
why white should be any worse
and black can just continue with natural
moves rookie 8
knight to d2
bishop f6 hitting the queen and now it's
very important you play the right move
here
bishop to e5 anything else white will
start losing material because bishop f6
does come with a skewer
so please do not uh
don't just move the queen
do block with the bishop
take the trades in the center
and rather than move back this way we
see white
go to f4 and the point is you're putting
more pressure on the position
and stuff like knight c4 maybe a knight
e4 can be a bit stronger if this knight
ever moves you are threatening stuff
like queen f7 or knight f7
which
even if it may not be objectively best
would scare me if i had the black pieces
but okay rook after e1 just developing
and we see both sides finish their
development very naturally and here i do
think white
stands better i think the knights are
more active i don't really see
i mean i guess this light square bishop
does hit the pawns so white does have to
be careful of that but the rook
placement the active queen the knights
are ready to jump into active positions
this knot on e5 is already pretty good
i don't see why white would be any worse
and black clearly has these weaknesses
on the c file and a file the pawns just
are not helping each other out so i
think this one does favor white i i
don't see
why black should go for this line but i
figured i should mention it because it
it is possible materialistically it is
fine but positionally i i don't believe
in it all that much
gabriella schmoller just subscribe thank
you
all right
so that covers the dubai ready defense
um i'll give you guys just a couple
seconds in case there's any questions on
that otherwise we're going to move into
the mackmanson gambit
all right i'm not seeing any big
questions about the positional stuff
it's time to start talking about
exciting chess we're going to get into
the nackmanson gambit there are many
move orders to reach this and some may
be wondering why i'm including this in
the scotch course um but it's because
sometimes people will find themselves in
these positions um from the do already
where it's very positional and they
don't want to play this they want to
play something sharper something with
more attacking chances
so i'm going to give a lot of credit
here to our very own jonathan schrantz
for bringing the nakminson gambit to
life
a year or two ago really popularizing it
and really ever since he did his youtube
video on it it just kind of exploded in
popularity
um but
this will be the first time i believe
we've had enactments in
uh i guess
study on our channel so let's get right
into it
we're going to talk about the
the accepted nachman sin and then i
think the best way black can decline it
so the way you reach the nachman sin
from a scotch move order
well we have our scotch game right here
and after takes in bishop c4
after knight f6
the next sideline um i guess the first
sideline
that you can play aside from the
mainline e5 is to castle
and this is offering a secondary pawn so
um
why not take it
black can go right ahead
and here white has a couple different
ideas one they can start with rook to e1
this is the most popular move which is
met with d5 and then
moves like bishop takes d5 are possible
because after the queen takes there is
knight c3 you're attacking the knight on
e4 twice and you're hitting the queen
and the queen cannot take because of the
pin so
um
that that is its own thing but i figured
if you're going to deviate from the e5
lines you probably should play the
nakmansen a lot of only moves for black
couple only moves for white
but the nakmansen gambit
here is with knight to c3
and not only did you give up
your initial pawn on d4 not only did you
give up the pawn on e4
but now you're offering this piece
so we're gonna look at what happens if
black takes
which really opens up the chances for
white to attack like crazy
starting with bishop f7
you sacrificed one piece two pawns now
you're giving up a bishop
white's just giving all their material
away
and here
black should take the piece if they
don't if they go king to e7 this is
winning immediately for white with
either queen to d5 or even the very
simple bishop to d5 just bring the piece
out of danger you're attacking the
knight if this knight moves rook to e1
is going to hit the king with check
you're gonna run into some big problems
here
so
black really should take on f7
and now probably the most natural move
in the position
queen to d5
so it sounds like we have some people in
the chat who have seen this before if
you have not seen this before i want you
guys to take a guess at what black's
best move is here in this position
it's uh not
not easy
the queen is checking the king your
options are f6
g6 e7 and e8
we have our own alex in the chat
black's best move is to resign
yeah um
i don't know if the best move is to
resign
um okay we do have a suggestion for king
g6
um
which unfortunately just doesn't work
queen takes e4 with check the king has
to move again to the f file if you end
up going king h5
uh very funny pawn g4 checkmate exists
so um king has to move back somewhere
like f7
uh and here knight g5 is just crushing
it if king to g8 queen d5 is mate
and uh if king f6 there's a mate and
four here
queen f4
king goes back to g6
queen f7
and now the king is very quickly running
out of squares king h6
g4 threatening queen h5 mate so you have
to play g6
and after g6 there is the very beautiful
knight e6 check
and if g5 blocking the bishop instead of
taking the queen
queen h5 mate so
unfortunately king g6 just doesn't work
there's checkmates around every corner
the best move in this position
is actually the surprising king f6 but
we'll get back to this in just a second
i do want to cover the other two moves
king e7 and king e8
uh first
king to e7 this is a blunder uh on a
massive
massive scale after king to e7
there is bishop to g5 and at first it
looks like you're just letting it be
taken by the knight um i should also
mention if they block with the knight
rook f to e1
and then
knight to e5 and then queen takes
or sorry not queen takes rook takes uh
queen needs to guard f7 here
um is mate so
they they actually need to take it with
the knight and it looks like you're
giving up yet another piece but
the the very nice part about this is
black's king is on the open file you do
have multiple other pieces in the
position we're gonna start with knight
g5 threatening queen f7 to drag the king
out
and here
uh
okay there there's three tries that i
thought i saw really king f6 is the only
move to keep them
anywhere near alive
but okay let's say you're not a computer
you don't see king f6 what else can you
try
well what if you try just g6 something
really slow to develop your bishop
this fails to queen f7 king to d6
and
here
there's a very very fine move knight e4
check
anything else uh white is going to be
equal knight e4 is the only move that
will lead to a checkmate so if you are
playing the nakmansen you and you come
across this position you must remember
knight e4
this forces the king to e5
and now you're going to start using the
rest of your pieces to kind of build a
cage around the king and eventually lock
it down so rook a to d1
um this is immediately threatening
something like queen b5 or even rook to
d5 um just checkmating the king on the
spot
so knight to b4
stopping rook to d5
now there's f4 check king e4
and rook f to e1
so uh g6 something so like this doesn't
work and if you try b6 a very similar
story with queen f7
and if you try d6 it's just matin one so
unfortunately king e7 will lose because
of this
um
i do also want to mention after b6
trying to open up this side
queen f7 king d6 and rook a d1 check
after king c5 and rook d5
king c4 i just wanted to show this
position because uh one of my old chess
coaches
um
loved stochi's mate and twos
and right here is a mate and three so i
wanted to give this one if you're
looking for a nice little headache
try and find the mate in three
but okay we're gonna move on from this
king e7 bad move
don't ever play it but i do want to
cover king eight
king e8 does give some very nice
practical tries for black
um
in fact the king eight lines a lot of
them do lead to black still being
slightly better but white needs to be
very careful
there are a lot of players with the
white pieces who blunder and take the
knight with the queen with check but the
problem with this
is it opens up
or not really opens up it allows black
to block on e7 without um is needing to
spend another move to do so black
already wants to play bishop e7 and here
white is just forcing him to do that
so
unfortunately
this doesn't quite work just yet what
you should do
is go rook f to e1
hit the knight the knight is pinned to
the king so you you will get this piece
back don't worry
and there's two tries
um
i guess the first try we'll look at
is its own
mess of variations bishop to e7
but um
in this line with bishop to e7 here i
found that there's like a lot of forcing
moves
like only moves that black needs to play
just to survive and i think in the end
they're slightly worse so i don't
recommend it but i think white does need
to know what to do
so after bishop to e7 here
we see rook to e4
and black has like three different uh
tries they can go for if they try
something slow like h6 stopping bishop
to g5
there's a very nice
additional sacrifice of bishop h6
and okay let's say rook takes h6 this is
mate in one
and let's say they see the main one they
take with the pawn
well now there's queen h5 check drawing
the king out
and now after rook f4 bishop f6 queen g6
there's no way to save
yourself on f6 rook takes is going to
lead to the loss of a queen for black
so there is this they play slowly with
h6 something like that
there is also
rook to f8 which doesn't quite work out
there is bishop to g5 piling up on e7
and if d6 rook a to e1 and now all of
white's pieces start serving a purpose
black's best move is to take on b2 and
now white can just start taking on e7
and after queen to b5 check you do fork
the king and the pawn i don't think
black is getting anything out of this
should be fine for white
so that leads us to the best move for
black is to play d6
is to
kind of help open this up for our pieces
to develop and
kind of control this e5 square
but bishop g5 hitting the bishop yet
again
we have king f8 and black is going to
miraculously hold on
rook a to e1
met with bishop f6 so this is one of
those only moves that i was talking
about bishop f6 is the only way to
survive stuff like rook f4 is going to
be very nasty
maybe even taking on e7 followed by
knight g5 could hurt
so bishop to f6 really gets ahead of all
of this right away
and one of the common ideas white will
have is to play
b4 um
i'm just checking our chat again
um i did see o7 has followed thank you
for the follow
but one of the common ideas in akron sin
is to play b4 and shut down this idea of
them taking on b2 really gives us one
less thing to worry about
and now after something like queen d7
the point of queen d7 is to go to f7 and
trade off the queens normally white is
just going to avoid this
and keep the queens on the board
and now after something like knight g8
again trying to go to f7 um and get the
queen active
um but yeah after bishop h4 and h5
through computer defense black can hold
um
however
it's going to require a lot of prep from
black to know all of this but again i
don't think bishop e7 is the friendliest
for humans
if you do play bishop b7 as black you
really should have a lot of those lines
memorized now
some of you may be wondering why i'm not
covering all of the moves that is
because our own jonathan trance has
released a chesable course on the
nakmensen so if you do want to see any
of these nakmensen lines in more depth
uh definitely check it out on chessable
jonathan
you're welcome for the plug okay so
after rook e1 i don't like bishop e7
knight e7
is probably the absolute best try for
black
hitting the queen right away
and
if white ends up taking on e4 this can
lead to some immediate problems after d5
because you're hitting the queen with
tempo and opening up the lines for your
pieces uh which is not what you want to
allow black to do you're really wanting
to try and restrict them so the way you
do this is by taking with the rook
and now the knight is pinned to the king
so your queen is not attacked and this
does not allow d5 to come and hit your
pieces
there is c6 though this does hit your
queen this is actually black's best try
here
but white can just move queen h5 end up
hitting black back with their own attack
and after blocking with g6 queen to e5
now they're hitting the rook
so really the only move here for black
is to move the rook unfortunately this
is a pretty easy only move to remember
you just defend your piece
uh bishop to g5 attacking e7 again and
after rook a to e1 white may just end up
winning a piece back
so
black has to play very actively and the
most active way to play here is just
expand in the center pawn to d5 hitting
this rook and now the rook must move
and one of the very
common ideas in the nakmansen is just go
rook f4 and you're controlling the
f-file and coming down this way
unfortunately in this particular
position this does not work and it's
because of h6 and your bishop doesn't
really have anywhere to go
if your bishop goes to h4 is met with g5
and your pieces are being forked
and if you go bishop to f6 there is
still pawn to g5
and now this rook doesn't really have
anywhere to go that will help keep up
the attack
all right so uh really
no good place for this rook if you just
go rook d4
um they can take on b2 first if they
would like uh and then your rook moves
but now something like uh rook g6 even
or king f7 and they are holding on
uh looks a little scary looks like there
should be a way to punish this but
unfortunately there's no good way for
white to control the light squares
so they can't take advantage of this
king on f7
so
unfortunately
um we do have more comments coming in
uh ninja capo will this be on youtube
later ideally yes we're gonna try and
get this vod off of twitch and onto
youtube
and then
also asking to cover every move in chess
eventually
we'll get there
but okay um rook f4 doesn't work so
instead just drop the rook back
rook to e3 you are hitting the pawn it's
not that big of a deal
if they end up taking
um you can still move your rook to the e
file and you're looking to capture on e7
uh or even just take on b2 later
so black does best by just developing
they bring their bishop out
rook a to e1 bishop to e4 cutting off
the coordination of our heavy pieces
and now their bishop to f6
bishop h6
and rook takes c3
rook f8 i can't explain all these moves
i honestly cannot um the engine loves
finding moves that
we don't understand
but through again more computer defense
black is doing fine and i think this
this line specifically where black is up
to piece i think is a lot easier to
remember
than the bishop e7 lines the moves are a
little bit more natural
and if white isn't careful they can turn
this equal position into a loss very
quickly because black is up the piece
they just need to uh i just need to be
careful
uh don't uh don't let the heavies
coordinate
and take advantage of these light
squares because white doesn't have the
light scored bishop anymore
yes i know these moves are inhuman
and i had to somehow prepare a lecture
over them
but okay there's our king e8 lines
we're gonna get into the king of six
lines now
and then i will cover
uh the nachman sin declined
um okay so the king f6 lines um i don't
have them as wide
as the king eight lines um but we will
get into our nachman sin here after
knight c3
d takes bishop f7 king f7
queen d5
and now king f6
so someone who has done their homework
or watched any lecture on the nachman
sin
should know king f6 is the best move
here
and
black does seem to hold
so as usual taking the knight with the
queen immediately is not the best move
uh here it is met with bishop to e7
which looks
like it's going to cause problems
because you are cutting off this this
square for the king
but i assure you black is doing just
fine
uh if white goes knight to g5
is met with d5
queen f4 chuck
and bishop f5 so the bishop will come
and be defended by the king
this early in the game the king is is
already a part of it as a unit he is
helping to defend
white can go with rook to e1 to try and
get another piece into the action rook
e6 is a big threat if a6 is played rook
e6
is checkmate so be careful and if you
have the white pieces be on the lookout
um so we will see black go queen d7 to
stop this checkmate
white should still go for the check
anyway because this will force black to
give up the queen
uh and after king takes e6
queen takes c7
rook to c8 and queen b7
b8
queen a6 all these moves are rather
forcing so i won't be spending too much
time explaining them
black can take on b2
bishop takes b2
and now not rook takes because it will
hang with check
um king f7
and unfortunately black seems to be be
doing better
um you have a rook for rook
bishop for bishop
and you're looking at black having
what's one less pawn
you have a rook and two minor pieces for
the queen which materialistically is
already better
and the pieces
while they aren't all coordinated on one
specific target
are going to be pretty easy to
coordinate with each other
okay someone's asking if you sacrifice
the exchange on e5 does that help
um let's see
where that could be
um
i don't think it's going to be
oops
i most definitely just skipped the line
um sacrificing the exchange on e5
how
oh like five minutes ago oh
man i don't know
um if you include move numbers
um and the variation will be easier to
uh
to be able to uh
help i'm now realizing you guys don't
have access to move numbers so that's
i'll fix that for next time
um but okay
um that's unfortunate i am sorry that i
missed that
um
but okay
queen takes e4 is a mistake black does
have a defense there instead
um
you go rook e1 get the rook into the
position first
and now black's best move here
knight e7
if they do try something slow with pawn
to h6
this is pretty much refuted after rook
takes and rook f4 is a very nice
resource you have here so bishop d6 to
stop that
bishop to f4 trying to get rid of the
piece that's stopping your plan
king g6 and our king is going to be
hiding on h7 here
eventually
so while the king is kind of safe
queen d3 does run into this problem of a
discovery so it does force king g8
and now you get your both of your rooks
lined up for the back rank trying to win
a queen so
unfortunately while it looks safe at
first this is just um this is winning
for white there's no way to to really
stop this attack yet to give up the
knight and then in that case um while
material may be equal black's king is by
no means uh any degree safe
so h6 something slow like that is just
not gonna
not gonna cut it
so we do go knight e7
and now queen takes e4 your queen was
attacked you also want to get your piece
back let's take the piece
and now
another only move
king f7
king f7 trying to save the king now
if black tries something like d5 this
seems very natural it's protected
multiple times it's attacking the queen
this does fail to queen f4
queen f4 bishop f5 the same idea we saw
in one of the previous lines
runs into knight d4
they are hitting f5 again
there are better moves here as well but
again
uh check out jonathan's course on
trustable
but knight d4 is just going to be my
easy recommendation again uh rook e6 is
a big threat so they need to stop that
so queen d6
and now there are there are some nice
moves but i like queen g5 and after king
f7 you take on f5
and after queen f6 you can take on e7
and here
i think that white is doing just fine
uh no big problems white is actually the
one who is up the pawn now
um not the most beautiful structure at
the same time black doesn't have a
fantastic one on the king side either
i think this would lead to a very nice
end game for white
but
through research we have found king f7
will hold
and it's still better for black
after king f7 something like bishop to
g5 is very natural you pin the knight uh
get your last piece out
now d5 actually does work for
uh
black because now after queen f4 check
there is king g8 and the king does hide
and now we don't have a follow-up check
we can drag queen e5
um trying to put more pressure on some
of these pieces here
um
trying to see what else is at the the
ready but black can take on b2
rook moves
you will open up this file eventually i
also want to make the note taking on b2
with the queen
is a very very big mistake
um black can play h6 hitting the bishop
and your bishop has to either trade or
retreat
and after trading
i actually don't see what is wrong with
black's position anymore
uh the king is relatively safe and it
looks like black is just up a bishop and
a pawn so rook ad1 and king h7 this king
is just completely safe there's no way
in knight g5 doesn't help even if you
could um
you're going to be sacrificing way too
many pieces you're not going to have any
pieces left to attack anymore
so
queen b2 unfortunately doesn't work you
can't allow h6 to
come and attack the bishop now h6 can
come anyway
but the trade is a little bit different
because now you can take on e7
so
definitely differences in the position
but black's best try here is probably
knight g6 hitting the queen
you trade queens
you take their piece
and now after
c6
um
here we seem to have a problem white
will be getting this pawn back but white
is still down a pawn
and black has the bishop pair so if you
ask anyone who knows theoretical end
games or
likes you know those russian school boy
sayings of bishop pair is good
bishop perez good i think here the nice
open board the very healthy pawns that
black has does give black a very nice
end game i don't know why jonathan loves
this so much
i gotta be honest this one looks pretty
rough to play but there there is still a
game here if um you end up getting to
this position which i highly doubt it
getting here requires a lot of study by
both sides actually
but even if you get here black will
still have to demonstrate end game
knowledge and be able to convert so i
don't think it's the easiest thing in
the world
so
um yes
uh that's correct no one is going to be
finding these moves over the board
okay
so that's the nakmansen accepted which
is probably black's best try
but if black is trying to avoid all
these computer moves or they don't even
know what's happening and they're afraid
that white is super prepared
they can decline the gambit and there's
a couple different tries they have but
let me get into my recommendation here
of after knight to c3 um the most common
um way people decline is just trading
nights
if you don't know what's going on just
trading the pieces and accepting your
material advantage that you already have
is probably a safer way to go in general
and now let's talk about what white
should do
white should take back on c3 you don't
want to give up too much material and be
passive
and now
black has to make a decision on how
they're going to continue
uh the first move d takes c3 is a very
big mistake because of rookie one
and after bishop to e7 it looks like
you're fine
but knight g5 coming to hit f7 forces
black to castle
and here there's queen h5
and this is just a monster attack if h6
knight takes f7 and you're losing
material bishop f7 is actually going to
lead to a mate
and if you try bishop g5 well after
bishop g5
well look at that your queen has been
trapped if knight e7 bishop takes your
queen is still trapped
so unfortunately d takes c3
not good for black at all a little too
slow
instead they should look for something
more active
or um
even just shutting down white's play so
i quite like bishop e7 here um c takes
d4 you give the pawn back and now you go
d5 you can hit the bishop
and now black can start playing more
natural moves compared to what we've
been seeing while still maintaining you
know the bishop pair and a reasonable
pawn structure
with natural moves so all these moves
starting to make more sense to us
there's a pin white tries to break the
pin
black takes
rook to b1 getting on the open file
and bishop to a3 these moves seem so
easy now that we've gone through all the
computer stuff
but now bishop d6 and queen c3
[Music]
i think this is uh rather balanced and
if anyone's for choice it's probably
black with the extra pawn but white does
have some nice activity
so i wouldn't blame
uh black for choosing this
the other option they have rather than
bishop e7 right away is d5 right away
kind of forcing bishop to go to b5
and
bishop e7 is probably the best response
i do want to cover d take c3 here it is
better than before if rook to e1 now
black has the choice of blocking with
either bishop on the e file
and black or sorry white just doesn't
have the development to really take
advantage of this right now
so this should be fine
um they also have bishop to d6 right
away
which allows rook to come to e1 but
again blocking with the bishop on e6 is
always a choice
and here we will see white capture on d4
putting more pressure on c6
um
and here actually black needs to be
careful they need to be willing to give
up the pawn
the only way that they can claim to be
any better is just by developing rapidly
um
taking on c6 actually should be okay for
black because of this
captures on h2 move
and now queen d6 and this is actually
how black is going to retain an
advantage here
um so definitely some tricks both sides
need to be aware of after castles white
should take on e6 and then take on e6
again with the rook
and here like queen d7 and rookie one is
going to be fine
if black really wants to draw they can
actually force a draw um
with oh where is it bishop h2 here
and after king takes is just going to be
checks with the queen
until either 50 moves or three move
repetition
depending on if draw offers are allowed
or not
so
with this bishop to d6 line there is a
way for black to force a draw if they so
choose
which can be unfortunate for white
but okay d5 bishop b5 and bishop to e7
seems to be one of the major choices
and now after takes on c6 takes on c6
and knight e5
um if you take on d4 it allows black to
castle if you play knight e5 they cannot
castle if they do castle knight c6 and
they do give up a bishop which is one of
the main sources of black's counter play
being able to use both of the bishops
effectively
so um
they should defend the pawn
and now something like queen f3
threatening mate but also just getting
the queen to a more active position
in general
um black and castle
and now cd4
and here starts to wrap up our analysis
after f6 and the knight trades itself
off
we have bishop a3 offering the trade of
dark square to bishops and while black
is up a pawn they do have a weaker pawn
structure than white these doubled pawns
might be hard to make progress with
and after bishop to d6 i think you have
a very balanced game
and this is the nakmansen declined this
is probably what i think is black's best
shot against the nachman since i think
white should know this
again there's
plenty of other moves there's no way i
can fit in
everything about the enactments and
that's going to be its own 20 part
course if i try and do it so
again one last time if you want to see
them in deeper detail chances course on
chessable
all right
that is
our analysis we are done with part three
of the scotch this is the knight of six
lines in the scotch gambit
uh i will wait a minute here for any
questions and then we will wrap up the
stream here
man that was a lot
so much theory
we're gonna have to wait five minutes
because uh sounds like some people are
watching a little bit behind
oh it's a pleasure you guys are welcome
it's always great to do this for you
guys
yes again we are going to try and put
this up on youtube the release schedule
on youtube is a little out of order
right now so hopefully we'll be able to
get that all sorted out but uh
definitely planning to have this on
youtube for you guys
don't worry about it
all right well i'm not seeing any
questions come through
so i'm going to assume everything made
perfect sense everything's crystal clear
and everyone's going to start beating
everyone with the scotch gambit or
suffering
so thank you everyone for coming and
watching tonight this was part three of
our scotch series i'm nick risco you
guys have a good night
uh we will try and find someone to raid
i think tracy's gonna
get on that oh she wants me to end the
stream okay
yeah you can be overwhelmed there's a
lot but all right you guys have a good
night i'll see you next week